then you put the the sample if you like
into the x-ray machine and you've got
all this data how does that look /
manifests itself and then what do you do
okay so what you end up with is a
three-dimensional array a
three-dimensional image if you like of
where each element of the image is a
gray level single variable and that
variable tells you something about the
density of a small area of your sample
so it's just like a black and white
image except that instead of measuring
the amount of light bouncing off the
object you're looking at it you're
effectively estimating the amount of
x-rays that went through that point so
you're looking at the density you're
looking at the density is proportional
to density so what we do with it is we
have developed techniques based on
methods used in visual tracking so there
are a large community of people in
computer vision who look at time based
video sequences of people cars etc
moving through a three-dimensional
environment and track them may I
identify a person in the first frame of
the video and then they track them as
they move through and recover that
position at each point in the video like
what I might even after effects a big
motivation for tracking stuff for your
CCTV if you want to find out where a
person is or track a car through a
junction and see where they go the way
that we use that sort of technology is
we view our three-dimensional stack of
densities as a video sequence we take
slices through it and we move from the
top of the stack down through to the
bottom and as we do that the route gets
more complex so you start off with a
single root at the top and then it
branches as it goes down you get a more
complicated structure so we've developed
some tracking techniques that will allow
us to take one of our stacks converted
into a video sequence have the
biologists point at the very top of the
stack and say this is where the route
begins and then initialize a tracker
which then automatically follows the
route through copse of the branching and
produces a three-dimensional model of
the root by stitching together all the
different paths
sorry taking so once you've got that you
can create a description of the
three-dimensional structure of the root
so we we then go through our data and we
pull out branching points and angles
between between branches and so on and
from that we can extract what the
biologists call root traits statistical
submarines are the properties of a
particular route and then we can hand
that to the biologists and what they do
is they relate that to other
experimental things like the genetic
structure of the plant or the level of
compactness of the soil or the amount of
water and where the water is for example
because you're not being destructive you
can also then keep an eye on this over
time yeah we can particularly now that
we have the automated facility and we
can program it to scan a particular
sample every day two days whatever we
can risk on the sample we segment it
pull out the structures match them up
and see what the differences are so we
will be able to study the growth of
these things which you couldn't do
before because just got destructive
methods would make that impossible so we
use this for a variety of things the
main focus is on roots we are looking
now at a wide range of biomaterials and
we've done things like we've done some
work on leads we've done some work for
the food industry looking to the
longer-term really though the focus is
going to be on plants and plant roots
and what we're getting into is more
detailed measurements automatic
measurements of the growth of plants
we're looking at in more and more
detailed measurements of things like the
temperature and other effects on the on
the graph of the plant so we're
embedding sensors into the columns that
we use so we can measure other stuff and
we also have a related facility being
built that will allow us to look at the
top half of the plant and pull out three
dimensional descriptions of plant shoots
from sets of normal color images and
hopefully before long we'll have a
complete three-dimensional
of a living plant